okay let's get to hatred mail this may
be the rare left-wing hatred mail at
least to some extent before we get to
that a quick reminder of what hatred
mail is because it's time to make
America hate again Patriot mail written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom so
we I recently was hearing from a few
people who said do you ever get
left-wing hate mail and I do but it
often does not lend itself to hatred
mail I think that this week's hatred
mail may qualify as left-wing hatred
mail take a listen to this I'm not a fan
of Trump bleats boos soy boy and TV
types really get to me president Trump
isn't doing us badly what is the point
of criticizing so some communist hack
can get in Boerne blizzy the only dem
that makes sense is tools II and the
dims already screwed her you'll never
learn her Trump
2020 is the results have fun with that
I'm leaving the country
so someone who is threatening to leave
the country over Donald Trump being
reelected who says Tulsi is the only
good choice and doesn't like what I'm
doing and talks about soy boy and Tifa
stuff this seems like the closest to
left-wing hatred mail that we've
received right at least to some degree I
guess it's at least ostensibly or
putative ly left-wing patriot mail it's
rare but I guess it does exist and here
it is apparently from a Tulsi supporter
no less make sure that you know the way
to fight hate reott ism in your
community use the coupon code hey tree
at 40 h8 e RI ot 4 0 when you sign up at
join pakman.com you will save 40% off of
a membership and it sends a message to
the hey tree 'it's that you will not be
intimidated by their hate reott ism
thank you